[Music]
whoa where to begin this week well in
case you missed it I was off the grid
for an entire month from August 4th to
September 5th and I have the facial hair
to prove it as you can see my beard
actually even has a twitter account
already which somehow is a real thing on
the internet over the past 30 days I've
had no phone no email no Twitter and no
digital noise in my life whatsoever I
also didn't watch any news or have one
single conversation about politics the
entire time I was gone believe it or not
what I did do during this time was a
combination of writing my book relaxing
doing some gardening taking long walks
with my dog and spending time with
friends and family as I said in our live
stream yesterday I am beyond incredibly
grateful and humbled by those of you who
support the Rubin report on patreon and
on PayPal for letting me and my crew
carve out this precious bit of time to
rest rejuvenate and come back more focus
than ever before I also learned a couple
life lessons this past month including
that writing a book is far more intense
and introspective than you can possibly
imagine so just give me a little more
time on that one unsurprisingly the news
cycle kept on spinning without me and
I'm just now catching up on everything
that I missed from the terror attack in
Barcelona to the events in
Charlottesville to the devastation of
Hurricane Harvey and now Trump's
reversal of daca there's no shortage of
news for me to get caught up with for
this direct message though I want to
look forwards and not backwards and
instead share some thoughts on the
future of what we're going to be doing
around here
I consider today to be the first episode
of season 3 of the Rubin report our
first season of the Rubin report as an
interview show began two years ago when
we launched on Ora TV with my interview
with Sam Harris over the next year the
show began to blow up as we focus more
and more on free speech on the battle
for logic and reason to be put back into
public discourse about a year ago we
left Ora and went fully independent so
we could a hundred percent control the
content we were creating as well as the
business behind it I consider this phase
of our show to be season two I don't
know if any show out there has a more
diverse guestlist over the past two
years and
I intend on expanding on that going
deeper on the important issues that
we're talking about and more your
support allows me to do what I think is
right instead of focusing on what
content will make a dime whether
YouTube's deep monetizes us or the
algorithms work against us because of
dangerous or controversial topics that
we cover the Rubin report will continue
to cover the issues that really matter
having the detailed nuanced
conversations you'll never get on
mainstream news with this in mind I'm
thrilled to be launching season three of
the Rubin report with one of the few
people I find that consistently makes
some sense of the endless noise that
were constantly bombarded with Phil
DeFranco host of the aptly titled Phil
DeFranco show is one of the guys I turn
to to get unbiased sourced and credible
analysis of current events as one of the
first big youtubers around he's had an
interesting personal and political
evolution himself something he's done in
front of the camera for years now our
friends at learn Liberty are partnering
with us for this episode and Phil is
requested that his honorarium for this
show be given to the polycystic disease
foundation cause which is very personal
to him after the show learned Liberty
will be writing a check of 1,500 dollars
to the foundation and you can find out
more about this cause at PKB cure org
all right I'm back I'm bearded and I'm
ready to talk about the important issues
of the day if there's a specific issue
you want us to cover or a special person
you want us to talk to this season let
us know in the comments right down below
since I've been off the internet for a
while I assume that all YouTube comments
are positive and friendly now so I look
forward to seeing what you come up with
[Music]
you
[Music]